the ABC 27 Studios in Harrisburg in the
first and only Pennsylvania Senate
debate the key question was whether
Democrat John Federman was up to the job
after suffering a stroke more than five
months ago and you may notice these
large monitors that are behind us this
is part of our closed captioning system
and despite seeing the questions in
writing the man once considered the
candidate to beat at times struggled to
make his point here on raising the
minimum wage that's that's the most
American bargain that if you work
full-time you should be able to live in
dignity is well true and I believe they
haven't have any businesses being being
you can't have businesses being
subsidized by not paying individuals
that just simply can't evade to to pay
their own way Republican mehmed Oz has
been trying to capitalize on growing
concerns about the economy he's not
really cognizant of the real challenges
of business owners who've got to balance
that with employees thankfully we have a
solution and John you didn't answer the
question you can't put businesses out of
a commission in order to pay more wages
because they won't be the wages will go
to zero regardless of their performance
whether it was restoring the right to an
abortion on a national level for
Democrats or Rising crime for
Republicans both candidates largely
stuck to their campaign talking points
Pennsylvania embodies the political tug
of war in this country between Democrats
and Republicans Donald Trump won the
presidential election here in 2016. Joe
Biden in 2020 and in this year's Senate
race both candidates are sticking
closely to their party platforms while
at the same time attempting to show that
they're more Pennsylvania and less
Washington D.C it's a contest of
personalities political scientist Sarah
niebler has been following the race
they're both running as political
Outsiders right no one wants to be part
of the the Washington establishment or
or you know government in Washington
inflation is weighing heavy on
Pennsylvania voters well I don't think
anyone has gone to a grocery store and
and bought some eggs or milk or anything
like that and found out how much uh you
know they've increased for some party
platform is more important than debate
performance it turns into an argument
that's not
um in my opinion won't help me make a
decision it just turns me off and
Pennsylvania voters with so few Senate
races and serious contention could very
well determine which party controls the
Senate Kristin salumi Al Jazeera
Harrisburg Pennsylvania